Ashlin awesome speakers Alex Veloso
Alice got his PhD in Paris and then he
was old but he still is he tells me like
a postdoc in CWI and he's also one of
the research fellows in the quality
program so he's going to tell us about
some of his work in cryptography in
particular is your knowledge tsar we're
going to tell us about what's your
knowledge is for everyone and it's very
nice very nice construction that mixes
the use of quantum eric error correcting
code and also uses technique so in
complexity theory so good Hamiltonian
constructions at Sandy on Monday so as
Thomas said he is a talk on cryptography
but actually it's intersection of
cryptography DCs and crypto sorry in
quantum so these two give the basic
notions of every every part of these
three like the these three sets of
knowledge and hopefully everyone be
bored at least some part of my talk so
let me start by redefining what
interactive proof systems are and
everything starts with NP so and picture
formalizes the notion of what from
efficient proofread if occasionally so
here the verify we have a polynomial
time algorithm that's the verifier and
she wants to solve some problem but the
problem is too hard so she cannot find
the solution herself but she can verify
the solution someone provides her so in
this setting we assume that there is a
proverb
that's computationally a mountain that
provides her like right writes down on
paper and sends her some proof and given
the solution she can solve solve the
problem herself she can solve the
problem and formally we require we say
that a language or a promise problems in
NP if for years instances there is a
message that the prover sends to the
verifier that makes her accept and for
and here you can think about a
mathematical statement so a true
mathematical statement we should have a
proof that makes the verifier to accept
and if the statements false no matter
what the prover sends the verifier
should reject
but then computer scientists we started
thinking okay why why do we have just
one interaction between the plumber and
a verifier why can't we make them talk
and then this complexity class called IP
was defined and here we allowed the
verifier to challenge and to ask
questions again to the approver and here
we want that for the true statements
there is some strategy of the product
over that makes it very far except for
for false statements no matter what they
prefer answers in this mood programs at
the end of the protocol this verifier
should reject with high probability it
was shown that like it's like
interaction is very powerful so this
complex the class IP was shown to be
equal to 2p space its complexity class
that has all the problems that can be
solved in polynomial space and the moral
here is that interaction is important so
please ask me questions and and then but
then we can we we can go even further
okay ask why we talk just one program
why can't you have multiple provers so
in this setting we we have this for
instance to prove errs that they share
some common common strategy but after
that they cannot communicate and again
here we want that for two statements
there exist I structure different
approvers that make the very fact
scepter statements and for four
statements no matter what the prover
does what the provers do then the
verifier should reject with high
probability
okay in the classical case we can assume
it up lots of generality that's probably
one you can always make it one but in
crypto okay these models are good but
for crypto we could ask more and they're
all sorry NMIT
it was shown to be even more powerful
data space it's so to solve every
problem that can be solved in no matter
miss exponential time so in each model
is expected to be much more powerful
than appeared this one so and as I said
in crypto we want more and one thing
that we could ask here is zero knowledge
so we say that this problem is your
knowledge if at the end of the protocol
the very fire learns nothing from from
the interaction of the proverb so what
does that mean so formally we can open
the finance volume we have in one hand
we have the scenario where the verifier
really interacts with the proper but
here we are paranoid we want the pair
fire to learn nothing so we can even
think at the very fires malicious so the
very fire can deviate from the real from
her honest actions in order to gain as
much information as much as information
as you can and at the end of the
protocol she has some output that's some
random variable X and we say that the
protocols your knowledge if you can come
up with a simulator that's efficient and
there's not have access to the like
cannot communicate with the approver and
this efficient simulator outputs some
random output that here and then of this
random variable Y and we say that the
protocol is your analogy if the
distributed if X is in the single ship
of wine and defining what in this intro
is my different like you can be more and
more picky so for instance in perfect
zero knowledge one that the distribution
of these two random variables is exactly
the same if you have statistical journal
and you just ask for instance that the
distribution of two is statistically
close and finally in computations your
knowledge will just say that
efficient distinguished I cannot cannot
know if she's given the samples from the
first distribution or from the second
distribution so intuitively this is
saying that whatever the verifier is
learning here she could have figured out
herself because there is a simulator
that has some sort of transcript
that's indistinguishable from the
original one and I discovered this week
that I think Shafi had like she put
money on people trying to prove that the
story the same so it's on the web okay
at least for me the first time I saw the
general ah jeez it was a bit magical so
it's not clear if this is possible so a
chart just to give a quick example of
how you can achieve zero knowledge and
this will be done like by our show this
protocol for a zero knowledge protocol
for 3-coloring
so the verifier wants to know if like I
get a given graph is through Colorado it
means that if you can put colors on
their vertices such that every edge that
just two different colors so let's and
she cannot okay assuming P is different
- P she cannot do it herself so she asks
the help of approver that is a mouth and
can find such a such a coloring and one
thing that the cupola very could do is
just send the color into the verifier
anybody fire checks if the colors are
different and this particle is
completing the meaning that if the graph
is still color ball then a verifier can
can check it if it sound no matter what
coloring the prover gives the verifier
will find two two vertices connected by
edges with the same color but it's far
from easier knowledge right where the
verifier is learning its coloring that
she could not have cooked
herself so let's try something else
so let's the prover has discoloring so
the first thing that you do is shuffle
the colors we see later while and then
the player puts discover some some saves
and send the saves to the verifier but
then keeps the code keep the code secret
of how to open each each save the very
power picks one of the edges in 4-minute
at random and tells the prover I want
you to open the the saves containing
these two vertices they prove our
answers with the codes for the safe and
then they verifier just open the two
safes and see if the colors are
different and in cryptography shapes are
what we'll call bit commitments but for
the rest of this talk of continuum with
safes just and here again we have the
protocol is complete because if the
proofer followed this protocol then he
will always convince the verifier that
the graph is indeed through collarbone
if if the graph is not for collarbone no
matter which which color in the pure the
prover sense the verifier should should
find - should pick one edge that
contains two - two birds with the same
color which will give 1 over the number
of edges so with some with
non-negligible probability the verifier
will catch this cheating program and now
finally this protocol zero-knowledge
because the only thing that the verifier
is seeing here are two different colors
and more importantly two different
colors like that each one of them pick
an independent the uniform at random
because the prover randomized the colors
at first place
finally wide its computational your
knowledge because the the verifier could
for instance try to open all the saves
by brute force she can try - OH - all
the possible codes and if she succeeds
doing that she has the food coloring and
we know that we should this shall this
should not be possible because there's
no simulator that can find such a
coloring but we are in the quantum
problem oh sorry
let let me try to let me give what some
things that we know in the classical
setting so there is a seminal result of
a banner at all that they show that
everything that can be proved with to
prove earth like in this MIT setting can
be also proven in perfect zero knowledge
secondly it was shown that everything
that can be solved with one prover but
computation was your knowledge this is
this is the equivalent of one prover
interact proof systems if and only if
what one eye functions exist but finally
more important what's more important to
be proud of you we know very efficient
ways of having zero knowledge
protocols for NP and this is one of the
cornerstones of cryptography and this is
the building block for for different
constructions and and it helps a lot in
practice
but now I OKs as I said we are in the
quantum problem so let's quantize
everything that we can and for each each
version of this interactive systems we
can define its control version so for
instance for Q&A we can consider the
setting where they provide a verifier
there now panto and now the approver
sends a quantum proof to the verifier
and then she runs this verification
quantum verification arm written to the
decide to etcetera jacket or we have QA
p where both the verified approvers
exchanged messages back and forth and
finally you have to an IP where these
two provers are quantum where they can
share a share some entangled state and
then they they communicate with this
quantum verifier in order to make her
accept or reject the input actually we
don't need to quantize everything so it
was it was shown by in our UV that
actually we can assume that the very
first class code we don't have any loss
of generality if you assume more
approvers but then later like this
breakthrough result actually they show
that to prove is are sufficient like she
at all
quantum Merlin Arthur because actually
okay it's not only the gyration of NP
there's this intermediate class called
ma where the verification is randomized
but I won't talk much about it but it
actually is a quantum version of MA
and we know that assuming quantum in
this one proof interact through systems
this does not give any extra power
because qi p is a copy space but this
recent breakthrough shows that allowing
quantum in to prove errs is much more
powerful than the quantum case and also
for q may we expect it to be more
powerful than p and again here we can
consider okay can can we have quantum
tactical systems which are also zero
knowledge and so here again we are
paranoid and we assume that the verifier
could be malicious and cheat in order to
learn as much as you can and we assume
that at the end of the this protocol
with this caught improvement a verifier
output some quantum state row and here
we say that the protocols your knowledge
if you can construct some Paulino a
quantum for another time
simulator that outputs some quantum
state Sigma and again here we say that
your knowledge if the output of this
this malicious verifier in the output of
the approval of sorry the simulator are
indistinguishable and again here we can
have these different levels of zero
knowledge so can we say that it's
perfect to our knowledge when it's
gotten the this reduces measures are
exactly the same or statistical to our
knowledge when they're trace distance is
moral or again computational to our
knowledge if no efficient welcome to
this tincture can can decide which which
state is given as input
the puts here so these it seems like
there's a difference between this
definition if these are allowed to be
quantum states no the verifier and a
simulator they all allowed in this I
think they are allowed to have to put
quantum states but I mean so are the
definitions equivalent if you say that
these are just classical bit strings no
it's not the patient I think these you
require more and with these okay
any more questions
so the first result of quantum of sir
knowledge in the quantum setting was
shown by watches because actually at
first we don't even know if classical
your knowledge protocols are safe
against quantum adversary's in the sense
that if the verifier was a quantum was a
quantum algorithm we don't have any any
way of our a pure re we didn't know how
to do how to use the classical
techniques to able to be able to
simulate and this happens because
usually when you when you construct a
classical simulator here's one way of
doing it
the simulator there's some gas and then
the simulator tries to run some
computation and at the end of this
computation she she checks if the gas
was correct or not if the guys was
correct good but if it was not correct
she can only roll back she can roll back
and start again she guess again does the
computation and check if the gas is
correct so if the probability of
guessing correctly is good enough you
don't have to repeat this process too
many times and you'll have a simulator a
priority is not possible because
checking if the guessed correct is
measuring it's a management and this
could destroy information and what what
is showed here is that there is a way of
having a plan to rewinding in the sense
that if you if you try to you'll do the
gas you try to run your your your
simulation you measure at the end if
you're fine if you guess correctly good
but if you if you didn't guess correctly
the information is still there and it's
efficiently somehow recoverable and then
you can use an another process to
simulate until you have until you have
the right gas
then a long time Paris and then
broadband G song and Watchers they
proposed in 2016 the first zero
knowledge protocol for Q&A where we
assume that the prover are efficient
they prefer the prover is efficient he's
given a copy of the quantum witness that
is that when you want to use your
knowledge in cryptography okay the
prover should be proving an NP statement
but you don't want him to find such a
big name piece every statement we
usually assume that he's given it and
after that he's just running polynomial
time computation and here's the property
that we didn't know how to do in the
quantum setting so this there is a
result of Rodman's Oh is the first one
to achieve also this property but it's
somewhat complicated and and it has
several rounds also there are still some
room for improvement here no I mean that
the prover is given a QM a witness and
after that he runs just polymath on
computation
okay so that so to be given a QM a
witness means that you can do that
whatever power you need to add in a
position to QA is to get your dog it's
you don't need additional exactly
then last year with Willis Lobster and
heroin we actually show that MIP star as
in the classical setting what was shown
by Ben are at all if you if you have the
MP star you can assume it's zero
knowledge without loss of generality and
in particular combining is this recent
result is very beautiful because 4k at
least in my opinion because it shows
that you can prove that a program house
and innovative fire we only know this
bit of information so in this MIP star
protocol so for me it was a bit
surprising that we can achieve such a
such a strong statement in the quantum
setting and what I will try to explain a
bit more later is this technical tool
that you use here is what you call
locally simulate about codes and I'll
explain it a bit more later it is
because you can just you can always go
to from qmi peter MP star and I am
pleased start to DC KMIP star
and MIT stars certainly included in
canopy and also does your knowledge
person
and they're all actually you are a and
they are actually very exactly
oh yeah here's the urban equality and
not a containment there were a bunch of
results for also for journal for Q&A
that came more or less together so first
in a result which broadband we show a
very simple zero knowledge protocol for
Q&A and this is a in this same same type
of committee and open as as I explained
for the for the through color in case
and okay we shall separate okay we we
have this we use and you also use this
idea tool to show us some variants of
this protocol but then independently
Khalid Angelo VD kyun-jung
they also showed a cue and I seek a
protocol for qma with considering that
the the preventive Edifier they they
have some setup phase and batons
generally they also show Qantas your
energy art now sorry these two were
arguments contusion adjournment for Q&A
with constant time of course a number of
France and constant complaints honors
gap
and for the rest of my talk I'll try to
explain a bit more the main technical
tools that we have here so the idea is
to at least review some concepts that we
have already seen like this week and I
introduced a new samyaza news ones and
I'll prove that a simple result that qma
using perfect your knowledge and IP star
and this should contain out all the main
ideas for for the for the final okay if
I have time I'll try to explain a bit
more about how to put MIP star in
perfect zero knowledge on T star and now
of tractable it's one round we need at
least four provers so if the number of
provers that we have here is bigger than
4 then we're fine like you keep the
number of troopers but if it's smaller
than 4 you need hearing it for so there
is this loss of like you might increase
the number of troopers but it's always
just one around
any more questions the classical case is
there you need to - yeah so yeah so as I
said like this your knowledge particle
Ferrari it actually requires four
approvers so it still there is some some
gap between like the parameters
so yeah and complete first sound is
actually yeah okay yeah I'll get light
there but there is a to the protocol
goes I'd approvers should share some
state and you want to confirm with the
previous shares the state and do
measurements on the status as you
command and in order to do that you have
to encode this witness in an aircraft
encode and share among them and they
cannot know with like what's the
question that you're asking so the for
comes from the as far as we have the
best aircraft as well right departed to
need then is that for zero knowledge is
for it's just for MIT star like for this
technique for MIT star for yeah yeah you
can just encode things differently like
in the state I think the share is a bit
different and then it comes for free
yeah so give some steps back so as I
said we have an IP we have an algorithm
that verifies proof and this can be seen
as you have a classical circuit that
contains ante and or and not gates and
these secret receives as input some
string X and then you want to know
what's the output of this classic of
circuit so the NP question is there is
some input to this classical circuit
such that the output is 1 if I do some
real labeling of this gate of these
wires I can set all wires to have some
some value let's say Y something
I can label all of these all of these
wires again I considered a string that's
the concatenation of all of these bits I
call this the history string so we can
see this as the history string
okay NP computation so you can think
that like if you run this circuit how it
is and then put the values that these
wires have here this string has all the
all the old information the of all steps
of the computation of of the secret C
and the quantum cook in a sari and a
coup claiming Hyrum
morally what what what what we're doing
is creating some three constraint
constraint satisfaction problem that's
first checking if if some given string
is actually a history string
and secondly check if the output is run
right because what we want to do is and
there's one to know if there is some
some some input to the circuit that
output is 1 so we want also to know that
if the last one is equal to 1 so this is
my way and a very simplistic way of
seeing the cook-levin theorem and when
when you go to the quantum setting this
is the same idea that we use but because
of quantum quantum properties we need to
do it differently so if you have a
quantum a quantum circuit for 40 ma it
receives some input side and the Q ma
vilification ask if there is some
quantum state si such that when you run
this code on circuit and you measure the
first bit and the first qubit you have
an output one
here we cannot just cut copy and paste
the values of the circuit because
because of entanglement so you cannot
just have in this part in this part all
together so we have to do it in a
different way to show how how the
history of the computation is and that's
what we saw a couple of times in this in
the in this week we have the history
state of the computation is instead of
putting all side by side you put them
you stack them together and you do that
by doing a superposition over all these
snapshots of their computation so you
have the the summation of over time step
and a snapshot of that timestamp okay
and that's what we call the history
state of the computation
here the quantum complaining theorem
reduces qma verification to Hamiltonians
and this can be seen as quantum version
of CSP and again we check
if the state is a history state
and they dealt with this one
okay so that's why we so that's what's
going on when like every time a to due
process delegation of computation we
just care about hamiltonians and check
information because we're actually
checking this history state and then
considering its output I think we saw it
a couple times so but if you have
questions let me know
so the second topic that I want to talk
about is what America marketing codes so
should I go from like start slow or I
don't know oh oh basic it should be
basic basic okay good good so as in
classical computer science we want to
err practicals to not surprisingly
correct codes and quantumly and so
classically will you do this by having
some map of let's say k qubits to n
qubits let's go simple let's just try to
encode one qubit
and here we want to learn
we want to in order to make this
meaningful we want this mapping to be an
isometry what I mean is that if you have
two two states and have state Phi amps I
and then you have the encoding of Phi
and Phi
any product of this tool is equal to the
inner product of the of their raw states
and in order to be a good encoding we we
need an extra property that the distance
of the code it's more efficient because
the incubate space is much larger okay I
find that so we say the reason of the
code is D and B here to be 2 T plus 1 if
for every operation F that accident at
most T qubits of your state so if you
have the encoding of sign
and you do some operation that touch the
not touch n minus T cubed then it's
possible to recover the encoding of sign
okay so this is the simplistic way of
seeing error correction like like the
property of converted quantum error
correcting codes to correct errors and
an example of contour cracking codes is
based in code for instance so it Maps
one qubit into seven cubits and yeah
that's it
so okay now we know this quantum error
correcting codes exist so we know that
we can encode quantum data but we want
to do more right we want we want to do
not only like star sorry but when
computing it so so photo respond to
rotation
there are two main ways of computing on
encoded data and the first one as if
introduced yesterday is by transversal
gates
and in transit so date said to be
transversal so for assessing the 1 2 n
cubed code is that if you apply some
operation you on every fiscal bit of
your encoded state this is actually the
same thing as encoding this operation
you in the logical state so and this
type of operations that are very good
for for fault tolerance because it they
don't spread there too much and they're
good for fault tolerance so for instance
if you if you're looking into this teen
code we can see that for very easily
that the not operation X operation can
be done transversally because every
every bit string in the support of the
encoding 0 is just the negation of a
string in the support of link coding of
one and actually when we we can also
show less easily that any Clifford
operation can be done a fish can be done
transversely when you consider then
called encoding on this team code
so they're not no okay yeah no I think
it's okay I'm using one another okay
okay okay okay it well it's well known
that for so for instance for so for
still calls
the new Clifford's transversally
but it's well known that no air crafting
code can can can perform a universal
quad to computation transversally so we
need a different gadget in order to -
watching photo universal photon and
spawn temptation and one way of doing
that is using what we call magic States
and I'll define by example what I mean
by magic states so in order to do
quantum computation you need clifford
operations plus any non clifford gate so
for instance you can consider the the t
gate that map's
zero to zero and one to five a four on
one so it applies this complex phase or
when it receives one as input and the t
magic state
is what you call
is this quantum state and using so and
then what what has been showed that
using if you provided resources of if
you provided copies of these magic
states then you can actually perform the
key operation as follows so you have
your state size on which you want to
apply litigate you receive one of these
magics magic States key and then you
apply
these quanta operation
your places operation so first you see
not so we apply this see not here so
this is a Clifford gate that entangles
the magic state and your quantum state
then you measure your region of qubit in
the compressional basis and then based
based on this output you apply a big
gate that's also Clifford on on on this
second on the second qubit and if you do
the calculations you see that the output
if you do everything correctly then what
you were doing here is a pint tea on on
your original state design and so this
computation by what we call computation
by teleportation and here it's useful
because as I said this is Clippard and
this is also clifford and as i said for
instance for this teen code we know how
to do clip first transversally so if
you're given the encoding of sign and
encoding of the tea gate and you do
everything transversally here you have
the encoding of your author state
applied the tea gate
Oh peace a 1i yeah but this is kefir
that's an important thing
I used to read that you know someone
could corrupt gate each wire of the
computation so for now I'm just assuming
that instead of doing the computation
the raw data I'm given in coding and I'm
assuming no we're okay for the purpose
of this talk as from nowhere
but for now I'm trying I'm just
introducing the notions when you're
doing I actually actual for tolerance
what you do is perform gates and then do
our correction perform gates then do our
correction correct and continue doing
photons contemplation so think about
your knowledge already just correctness
of yes so presumably the point here is
correctness with noise for now okay for
any purpose on this talk I'm just that's
the only the question is why is because
quantum arc writing codes are good for
secret sharing as well so for instance
if you have if you have here the scene
code you have seven cubits and if you do
the calculations if you pick any two
cubits of the steam code they're the
totally mixed eight so they have zero
information about the about link of the
state
okay so so this this can be used for
instance for secret sharing but the
property that we need here is ought to
call similar bill similar at ability
so as I said here
this reduces matrix on two qubits is
always the say is always the Ptolemaic
state so in particular there is a very
efficient algorithm that's given to
qubits and outputs what's the reduced
matrix of the state on these two qubits
and his algorithm just outputs identity
so it outputs a classical description
over over the dis reduce sense matrices
and then this this inspires us to define
what we call the simulate about codes
and one property of the simulated ba
codes is that that there exist is
efficient Pascal algorithm
okay let's assume that the code this
code encodes one qubit into n n1 quantum
error correcting code and we fixed some
parameter K or sir s
and we say that this code is assimilate
able if there is efficient classical
algorithm that's given a subset of the n
qubits such that the size of the set is
at most the parameter s this similar
ability the parameter
and outputs they reduce this matrix of
encoding of some cubed cubed of some
cubed sigh 1s so let me okay after you
have this definition let me go back here
so if you're given a subset let's say
one like the fifth and the seventh
I want this algorithm thought put what's
they reduce this matrix so if you forget
what we have in the other positions what
the state of the what what's the value
what they state oh the reduced state
over over this encoding is it clear what
what I'm trying to do let me try to
explain again
what we're trying to do here is simulate
parts of the code so instead of we're
giving this big arrow crackling code and
we're just saying okay if you look to
just one or two qubit saw of this big
encoding does it have an information or
can we efficiently compute what's the
value that's there so as I said for this
teen code for if the set has at most two
qubits it's fine but it can be easily
seen if you pick three of them then it's
not the case anymore
so for instance if you pick the three
first qubits here you have the substring
0 0 0 but here you cannot so yeah I'll
get later for the construction but s is
a function of the distance so the first
question is can you have for an
arbitrary yes have a simulate about code
and what we show in our result that yes
you can do and you do it by just doing
today iterations so instead of having
once in code what you could do can you
can do it again and concatenate with
itself
I'll compute raisins for every physical
for every qubit of the encoding of your
state you can call it again with a steam
code and for instance if now you pick
three cubits here they're not a total
mixed state because we see that they
cannot be but they are just the three
first qubits of the encoding of a total
mix state because we know that this
original encoding if you just look to
the first qubit this is the total mixed
age so this is a random bit so these
three values here is just encoding of a
random bit and that in so this reduce
this matrix can be efficiently computed
guess what's confusing me is are you
only asking for a projection or are you
going to simulate some operations I want
you know for now is just four encoded
States I see but yeah I mean at all
address that okay any more questions
is it clear what I'm trying to go for
now it's mathematically clear but I
don't know why you're doing these things
okay together I'll get there yes I
actually just asked okay we're
simulating encoded States but we want to
do computation on quantum states so for
instance you have the encoding of sine
as I said if you apply X gates on each
of the qubit each qubit at the end I
have been coding of X of sine because X
can be applied transpersonal so our
definition of similar ability actually
asked that if you that that you can also
also simulate every state that an app
shot of the computation of X
transversally so here we want to
simulate these snapshots
of the computation as you saw either
condone transversally
if you do they quickly take calculations
computing the snapshots on transverse er
computation is the same thing as
computing or encoded States because then
my trace is cyclic so you can use these
nice properties but the the main
obstacle comes when you do magic magic
state gadgets
because okay as you saw here we know
that the this magic States gadget can be
implemented with Clifford Clifford gates
and measurements so the problem here is
how can you simulate the measurement
that you have here so hopefully it works
because we're lucky and here the output
the output of these of this measurement
is with loyalty have zero in priority
have one so we know the exact
distribution of this outcome yeah
depends on what your efficiency metric
is in if it's in a number of qubits but
your number of T gates is constant then
this follows from the regardless
MacNeill theorem if you want to be
efficient in the number of T gates at
every T Gate you're going to split in
two and so it's not so efficient anymore
now our argument is independent of the
number of the gates because of the
following imagine to have a computation
that you have some some big say sorry
and here do let's say a tea and then how
demurred and some like that
but now we're encoding everything if
you're doing the gadgets for every every
every part so at this stage everything
is encoded so we know by this property
that you can simulate then we're doing a
ticket and then by this property that
you can do in the computation during the
computation is phased of the computation
you can simulate every snapshot then we
are done then this part is fine but then
everything here is encoded again as long
as s is sufficiently small yes yeah yeah
you have to tune the parameters yes
so yeah having defined the properties so
what to show in this work with William
and and Harry
is that if you pick let's say if you
fixed an s and then if you can cut any
skinny code by log s plus 3 times so if
you fix some K then the this K
concatenation
these are simulator bomb
so the conclusion here is that for any s
for any constant s there is a constant
size error correcting code that's
simulate a bomb and finally
we can now that is that okay now I'll
put these two ideas together and see why
this amount ability is important
so let's go back to our qma verification
it consists of some sets I'm Sam Okyere
bit 0 and then quantum gates
like when you're doing a QA of Education
you can assume a different a different
circuit anything which is the following
first instead of assuming sigh it
assumes to receive the encoding of Sai
under some error correcting codes first
you have to check this in code is
correct so some error detection here
and and and you also receive more in
Silas more clear beeps and here the
first thing that the verifier does is
first creating magic States
and encoding everything
so in this step after doing the error
check and and creating magic States
creating magic state Santa gates
everything is encoded so after that you
can just apply every every every every
every gate either by do it transversally
or either by doing transversally or
using the magic states that that we
created in this face so my claim here
that by ok and at the end of the perk of
course you have taught put just one beat
so with just the code the first bitten
and measure it so my claim here is that
by doing this encoded version of the KMA
verification protocol completeness and
soundness are exactly the same because
complete is extrema because if sai is if
encoding of pi is given here you accept
with with exactly the same probability
as the original verifier or we would
accept its i but you could not give an
error correcting code you are a reject
so it can only decrease the probability
and what okay in a more complicated
version what we're showing with Harry
and and William is that the history
state
is also simulate Abel
so if you're given the history state of
this encoded computation when I look to
just a few cubits of this proof you can
know exactly what they produced less
matriarch a you know you know very with
a very good precision was the reduced
matrix there because um a dozen how does
not have a perfect completeness if your
cumulative cash acceptor priority one
and it's exactly the same deal an
s-parameter in that statement is it the
simulator bow or s simulate relateable s
you fix s if it's a coin s is a constant
as big as you want and then you pick
your correcting code such that is that's
simulate able and then here you pick s
qubits and it's yeah yeah so the point
is yeah that is this algorithm what put
some reduces matrix that's exponentially
close like financially small in the
original symmetric of the history state
so we didn't observe this in in in this
paper but then which Broadbent
we realize that actually this shows that
this radio what's called a reduces
consistence of local reduce this matrix
problem and this problem is as follows
we don't prove these for fermions nor
something like that no I just know
quantum states I don't know okay okay if
you have a quantum state but yeah
they're related
imagine you're given reduces matrix
reduces matrices they're supposed to
come from this big quantum state let's
say Sigma so if you even let's say Rho 1
Rho 1 Rho 2 and so on so we're given a
bunch of variance matrix matrices and
the question is is there a quantum state
that's consistence with all these local
parts
and in 2006 these are shown to be in qma
oh sorry yeah to be clear me hi no it
was shown to be in qm e and q ma is in
what we say be two days to this problem
so it means it if you can solve this
problem in unit time then you can solve
Germain but these these what we call
torii reduction so we what you showed is
that this problem is qme hardener to
reductions but these are not this is not
a standard type of reductions and they
it doesn't it's not exactly what we want
because for using protocols you cannot
just replace a protocol for CL DM for a
protocol for any you may complete
problems because you have some issues
with complement and so on so what to
show in which broadband is actually that
CL DM is Jimmy Hart
and thus give me complete so this is a
byproduct of our of our constructions
here okay yeah I'd like to go back to
MIT star maybe Alan jeal okay or I can
okay I'll do something simpler
so instead of showing approvers I'll
show how this very simple product is
your knowledge protocol for qma words so
again here so we have a I'm showing that
um a has a simple delay
with someone program and compressions
your knowledge
so that is the following the proverb
holds some state some simulate above
witness so they are going here that we
can assume now that instead of having
just the the history state the prover
has a encoded history state that's
simulator ball right disproven puts the
one-time pad on this on this simulate
about state to hide it and commit to
these values a and B and sends
everything to the verifier
so the verifier now holds some encrypted
version of the simulate about history
state one thing I didn't mention is that
these checks are all local okay
encrypted because they have a one-time
bad now just to hide everything then the
very far just tell the prover I want to
perform the ice test and let's say that
this eye test just touches s qubits and
then the prover just opens the
commitment the corresponding qubits
so this protocol okay my claim that
first this protocol is complete because
if the prover is if there there exists
some state that makes it very far except
the prover does everything honestly and
then the very far except with high
probability at the end it's sound
because if this committee okay assuming
these comedians are binding so the
prover cannot change his mind off
watching inside the safe then then by
the sounds of the qme protocol the
verifier rejects with no knowledge of
probability but what we can show that
this problem is lost at this protocol is
also zero knowledge because the only
thing that the verifier is seen here is
s cubits that are open that's the only
thing that only part of the witness at
the very fire scene but these can be
simulated by using our simulate about
proofs so so there is a d'azur on the
proof the verifier here since it's one
time pad at the prove it just say seize
the total mixtape
answer some row wide that he could have
computer she could have have have
computer herself more identities let's
say and some commitment a and b but
since this is hiding this is not giving
an information you know is how with
multiple provers you'd instead of
measuring them the verifier is
delegating the measurement to the
provers so the approvers okay that is
that the provers have four approvers
they share an encoding so you encode it
again but an outer encoding and then
share this history state with an arrow
crackling code and then the verifier
needs to command
what measurements to do on on a few
qubits
still if you want to translate your
translation but you have this parrot yes
yeah all the pet is not the one-time pad
is not needed yeah no track the
commitments compression so this is these
are what if this is a string this is
change the point is so the commitment is
just saying okay
it prefers to be sure that the approvers
have fixed a quantum state and whenever
you tell them to measure a few qubits
they're still measuring on the same
phone state that they have committed so
that is that by not have information
they commit to a state right away and
that's done
clear Marlys no clear first your city
was computational zero now you gotta go
to perfect I don't know here's perfect
here the computational so you can always
simulate the reduce this matrix so this
part is statistical or perfect to index
right computing these statistical so if
I just reveal if I just reveal a part of
the state I don't have computational
sample assumptions here but here the the
prover somehow has to commit in the
state and this commitment to the state
is computational
just here you just commend the prefers
to measure a few cubits of the state so
here first yeah in different ways you
say that measuring a few cubes of the
state he they commit the whole state you
do test for that but in the honest case
when you're just measuring the the
qubits you don't you don't have to see
the whole state you just see the
specific part that you know how to
simulate
okay
just knots your honor and I just I'd
like just to finish with some open
questions and I can't I'm happy to
discuss things offline so first of all
okay we have okay have been developing
better and better as your knowledge
protocols in the quantum setting but is
wife why what where can you use it and
basically it can be classical your
knowledge particles can be used in to
construct other primitives it can be
using very like in a lot of different
ways and quantity we still don't know if
this is possible or not certainly okay
we know that MIP
is equal zero knowledge MIT we know the
ni P star is equal to zero knowledge fu
star can you go further so if you give
even more power to the provers they can
share any non signal strategy is zero
knowledge which making it a smaller
class or does it or it's still the same
and finally we have we're getting better
known non-interactive is your knowledge
for 4-koma but none of these approaches
they did this in the standard c RS
models okay can you have more efficient
zero knowledge like more standards
you're not actually your knowledge for
forgive me and i think that's all thanks
[Applause]
[Music]